OK, so I'd like to go now to
the next segment of the course.
Think
you can probably appreciate
little bit better this triangle
I had on
before about how what
biochemists did was they tended
to break cells
open, look at the component
parts, through other things in
there,
and then proteins.
But an awful lot of stuff
having to
do with function is proteins,
and what geneticists,
the discipline of
genetics would do,
which made mutants of living
organisms, and
that looked at how function was
affected by mutating individual
genes, how those were both very
powerful approaches.
Genetics told
you what was really important,
and biochemistry told you how
it worked
at a molecular level,
but the real problem is knowing
whether this
thing you had doing something
in the test tube was actually
the one that
did it in life.
And I think I told you when
Arthur
Kornberg isolated the very
first DNA polymerase,
he was able to copy DNA.
And he got a Nobel prize,
and it was the first enzyme
that could copy
DNA, and then John Karens made
a mutant that was lacking the
enzyme.
And the organism was still
alive.
So therefore,
it couldn't have been
the DNA polymerase that was
copying the chromosome.
It actually turned
out to be a DNA repair enzyme.
So, if you can actually unite
genetics and biochemistry,
if you can take a mutant that's
broken in a
function and you found your
protein was missing,
or vice versa,
then you
had a very, very powerful
insight because you connect your
knowledge
of what was physiologically
important to the biochemistry
that
you're doing.
But it was really,
really hard for years,
and only in
very rare occasions did some
geneticists have a mutant that
suggests so strongly that some
biochemists would look,
or some
biochemists would have such a
powerful result that they talked
to
a geneticist and see if anybody
had found the result.
And the power of recombinant
DNA, although it started a
biotech
industry, and it made possible
the sequencing of the genome,
there's
another level up one higher in
conceptual understanding.
And what
it did was, it let you go back
and forth between here and here.
You
wouldn't have any problem now
if I gave you the sequence of
the gene,
you can order it.
You could stick it in a cell
and make massive
amounts of the protein.
You purified it twenty-fold and
it would
be pure, whereas before you
might have had to purified it
fifteen
thousand-fold out of 1,000 g of
cells, and you would have had to
been a very good biochemists
with 15 steps in order to purify
it.
So, you can go from the
sequence of the gene to the
protein, or if we
got a protein and we wanted to
know which gene we'd just
sequence a bit
of the protein,
use that genetic code,
work ourselves backwards to
some possible sequences,
then go looking for the
sequences, and then
go find the gene.
So, what recombinant DNA allows
us
to do is close that loop.
You can go from genetics to
biochemistry and
back and forth.
Now everybody does everything
instead of it being
isolated disciplines,
which it was when I entered the
field.
So, all
of the stuff depended on the
development to clone particular
pieces of DNA.
And I want to make clear right
at the beginning,
there's a couple of uses of
cloning that are in popular
usage right now.
What we're talking about in
this
lecture is cloning a piece of
DNA.
What that means,
is I'm going to
take a particular segment of
DNA, say, cut it here,
and cut it there.
And I'm going to take that
piece, and I'm going to do
something to it
that lets me amplify it and
make many, many copies of that
piece of
DNA.
And cloning of anything else
you make a whole lot of copies.
So
that's one use of the word
cloning.
The other use,
which you see in the
popular press all the time,
is cloning an individual,
thought being
there: you would take the
nucleus from the cell of the
individual,
put that nucleus into an egg
that didn't have its own nucleus
moved,
and now you hope what you get
out of that is an organism that
has all the
same genetic content as the
starting individual.
And in fact,
although it sounds very good in
paper, is you're probably
beginning to see it's not the
panacea that people thought it
was,
or that we'd have to worry that
in 10 years, all of my MIT
students
would be clones of the
brightest person in the class or
anything like
that, because other stuff
happens, that you get to in
advanced
biology courses,
but there are modifications of
DNA.
There's all
sorts of stuff that happens to
it, so it's not identical.
And so many of these cloned
organisms, like Dolly the sheep,
that was famous,
died early with,
I forget, arthritis and things.
So,
there are a lot of problems on
that score.
But that's the other use of
the word cloning and that's not
what these next three lectures
that we
are talking about cloning a
piece of DNA.
And that was the big problem
that faced the field,
certainly when I was an
undergrad and even when I
was a grad student I was
interested in synthesizing
pieces of DNA,
and
it was one of those things that
people said, why are you doing
it?
Well, because you could try to
do it.
What if you got a piece of DNA,
like Gobind Khorana,
who's my colleague,
who got the Nobel prize
for synthesizing the first
gene.
He synthesized it.
It was a tRNA
gene that was 120 nucleotide
base pairs long or something.
He
synthesized it.
He'd shown you could do it.
But you couldn't do
anything with it.
And there were sort of two big
problems.
One was
the fact that this DNA,
although it's not a monotonous
tetranucleotide.
It's pretty hard to tell.
Each one
of these things is a base pair,
and human DNA has 3 billion of
those.
And a bit down here,
doesn't look very different
than the bit out
there.
And it certainly wouldn't looks
very different than the bit of
DNA that's 2 billion base pairs
over on the other side of campus
or
something.
So, there is no way to take DNA
and cut it reproducibly,
so
you to get fragments.
What you could see from first
principles was what you would
need was magic scissors.
And what would
the scissors look like?
Well, it would have to be
scissors that could
read a sequence as there's
nothing else different.
You know it's a
regular backbone,
and it's only four nucleotides.
So, if you wanted to
cut DNA in particular places,
you had to have scissors that
could see
a sequence.
And furthermore,
you can see they couldn't just,
there
are the hydrogen bonding parts
of A and T or G and C because
those
are stuck together there in the
middle of the DNA.
So, you'd need scissors that
could somehow find a sequence
and make a
cut.
And those were found.
I'm going to till you about
those.
They're called restriction
enzymes.
So that was part of the thing.
The
other thing was,
imagine I could cut out this
fragment.
And they gave it
to you, and I said,
great.
Now I've got it.
Would you make me a lot of
copies of this DNA?
Could you do that?
Let's say, you
now know how to transform the
principle that we saw back with
Avery.
We could take naked DNA and put
this fragment into the cell.
Would it replicate?
What do you think?
Anybody remember?
No?
OK,
we talked about some other
languages, right?
But one of the things that's in
the DNA is the genetic code with
all the
genes.
And we can find the reading
frame.
Remember when we talked
about an origin of replication.
I said that was sort of,
at least for
E.
coli there's one origin.
In eukaryotes the origins are
spaced
out along the DNA.
And every time you have a round
of replication,
it
starts with one of those
origins and then goes.
So the chance of this
piece of DNA by chance is going
to have an origin is pretty
small.
So if I put it into an
organism, it's going to sit
there, if you're
lucky, maybe degraded because
it's got blunt ends,
or even if I made
it into circle it probably
wouldn't replicate because it
probably
doesn't have the word in the
DNA that says "start a round of
DNA
replication".
So, the other overarching
principle of DNA
replication is you somehow have
to take the fragment of DNA that
you're
looking at, and you have to
attach it to an origin of
replication.
Now, if you have an origin of
replication and you have a
fragment
of DNA, and you put it in the
cell, now you'll get a lot of
copies of
that piece of DNA.
So that's what recombinant DNA
is all about in a
really, really simple form.
I'm just going to take you now
into
increasing sort of levels of
detail.
So, let me just sort of give
you
just sort of a really broad
view of this cloning,
and then we'll sort of
start to dive in to some of the
fancier techniques that
have come out of this.
We'll talk about DNA
sequencing, and
PCR, and stuff in the next
lecture.
So the first principle here is
to
cut the DNA,
and I know you may think this
is sort of baby talk,
but
this is how I think.
If you really think about this
stuff, this is what
it really is.
With sequence specific
molecular scissors,
these
have the rather odd name.
They're called restriction
enzymes.
I don't know if any of you know
why they're called restriction
enzymes,
and although I'm sure that some
of you have used them in your
UROP to
cut up pieces of DNA.
But what that does,
these are enzymes,
as I'll
tell you, that recognize a
particular sequence.
And they
always cut at that sequence.
The value of that is you can
reproducibly cut DNA exactly
the same spot,
and the spots are
specified by whatever sequence
that particular pair of scissors
knows how to read.
Then the next thing we have to
do is
we need to join the piece of
DNA to an origin of replication.
So the
thing that carries the origin
of replication is called a
vector.
And
usually, not always,
these are circles.
We'll consider the ones
that grow in E.
coli are most of the time,
or in bacteria,
mostly
circles.
They are the ones that are
broadly used for most cloning.
So, we'll talk about those.
What makes a vector?
What it has to have
is an origin of DNA
replication.
They usually have something
else.
We could call it a selectable
marker, but something like
a drug resistance.
If any of you have done cloning
in a
UROP usually it's something
like a gene for making the cell
ampicillin
resistant, or tetracycline
resistant, some antibiotic that
would normally kill the cell.
So you can tell,
does that cell have
that vector or not because the
cell starts out ampicillin
sensitive
but it acquires the vector
that's replicating it,
also acquires
the gene that gives it the drug
resistance.
But if we're going to cut that,
if we're going to join a piece
of DNA
to that, we can't join into a
circle without breaking it.
So, we need to
cut the vector at a unique
site.
And we would use a restriction
enzyme for that.
And you can also see in
designing a vector,
you'd
want something that only has
one site.
So, what we would have achieved
from this conceptually as we've
now got
this, this is the vector,
its origin of replication here,
and let's say
ampicillin resistance,
for example,
as a selectable marker,
the gene for
that could be encoded here.
And we have the fragment of,
if you want to
that down, just put it down on
the floor, I think.
We've made the
point at this stage.
Thanks.
What one has to do is to join
this
piece of DNA to that.
And we'll go to the molecular
details of this.
But, we'll join the fragment to
the vector, and actually this
was
something that was already in
molecular biologists' toolkits,
have
been studying DNA replication.
That's DNA ligase.
When we finish
an Okazaki fragment,
we had to seal nicks and the
enzyme that
did that was an enzyme called
DNA ligase.
So, molecular biologists
basically had the scotch tape
or the glue to join stuff back
together.
What they were missing for
many, many years where the
sequence-
specific molecular scissors.
So at this stage,
if we were doing the
recombinant DNA,
we now have a vector.
We now have a piece of DNA
joined to it.
In fact, we probably have a
whole
other mess of things that
happens along the way.
But at the moment,
they're in a test tube.
So, if we want to have this
thing grow, what
do we have to do next?
We are going to have to get the
DNA from outside
the cell inside the cell.
That's the word;
we need to transform the
DNA into a cell.
Again, the word transform,
that goes
back to those transformation
experiments with the
Streptococcus
pneumonia going from smooth to
rough, and you are taking stuff
from
the cell that transformed them
from rough to smooth,
whatever, that's
where the word came from,
but we now know it's getting
naked DNA inside
the cell where it can be
replicated.
And then the next thing we need
to
know is, what cells have
acquired this vector that at
least
has the vector.
We'll settle for that in the
beginning, and to do that,
you need to select for the
marker on the
vector.
In the case of this one,
we would start with a strain
that's
killed by ampicillin,
and then we just plate it out
and ask for guys
that are ampicillin resistant.
And, you can see that there is
another class of problem
because if we had uncut vector,
and there would
probably be,
for sure, some of that in our
mix, that would make the cell
amp resistant.
And if we had an insert,
it would be amp resistant.
So, if we really wanted to get
into this, we'd have to do some
more work
to sort out what's on there.
But that's the basic stuff.
I suspect
most of you know this
practically since kindergarten.
But that's the
overall framework into which,
now, I'm going to start
layering
different pieces of detail.
And the next part,
again, some of
you may know.
I don't think it will be a
totally foreign concept.
You
are probably familiar with
this, that what are these
restriction
enzymes?
The actual word is restriction
endonuclease.
They are
often usually called
restriction enzymes in a lab
parlance.
Nuclease is something that cuts
the nucleic acid,
and endonuclease is
one that doesn't need a free
end.
So, it can cut in the middle of
the
sequence instead of nibbling at
the end.
That would be
an exonuclease.
So, these things have names
that
tend to be something like
EcoRI, which has something to do
with where
they are derived from.
And a typical one,
one of the very first
ones that is still in really
wide use, is EcoRI.
And this recognizes
the sequence G A A T T C.
Now, you'll notice that if you
read
the sequence in this way it's
the same sequence when you read
it on
the other strand.
It's called a palindrome but be
careful because
palindromes in English,
those are words that you read
from the front
to the back;
they're the same.
In an English letter,
it doesn't matter
whether it's in A here or an A
there.
But you guys know something
about DNA structure.
There's a five to
three prime polarity.
So, reading this way doesn't
look at all the
same.
It's totally different.
But reading in this strand,
we say
that's five to three.
The thing that's identical is
the reciprocal
sequence on the other side.
So there is this,
you see G A A and G A
A but it's not like the English
word palindrome,
so don't get yourself
mixed up about that.
Anyway, what this will then,
what
this enzyme then does,
is it cuts to the side here.
It cuts
symmetrically.
And what it generates then is a
G three prime
hydroxyl.
Remember the ribose?
If we have, say,
an A there, this is
the three prime position,
and that's the five prime
position in the
sugar.
So, it leaves a three prime
hydroxyl, and is also then
leaves a
five prime phosphate.
So, we'd have A A T T C here,
and
then on the other side,
we would get the reciprocal
thing.
So, we'd have
G with a three prime hydroxyl,
and then over A A T T C like
that.
So now we've got a break here.
We can pull those apart.
But one of
the nice things you can see
right from this is that we're
generating
five prime single stranded
ends, and this one is the
sequence A A T T C.
This is A A T T C here,
and these guys,
if they could get together and
line up as they would here,
they'd be able to form hydrogen
bonds.
So, if you take an enzyme like
EcoRI, and we took,
let's say, a
circle that had a single EcoRI
site, G A A T T C,
if we cut it with
the restriction enzyme we would
make nicks.
And if we kept it cold,
all that we'd have is DNA
nicks.
And if we warm things up a
little
bit, there's only four hydrogen
bonds that are holding that
together.
So, the thing would linearize
and just flop around in
the breeze.
If we cooled it slowly,
the thermodynamically most
favorable
state, the lowest energy state,
would be with those ends coming
back
together.
So, we could then add DNA
ligase.
If we added these up and
added DNA ligase,
we could reverse the process
and go back and forth,
EcoRI to cut it,
ligase to ligate.
And then, the beauty of
recombinant
DNA is this rejoining part
doesn't see what's out here or
what's out there.
All it sees is the little ends
that
are generated by an EcoRI site.
So they take some of my DNA,
and I'll
cut it up.
I'll get a zillion EcoRI
fragments, but they'll all
have the same little
overhanging bit that's
complementary to the vector.
So if I take a vector cut with
EcoRI, and I take some of my own
DNA and I mix them,
I can get a little fragment,
get in between the
vector, and it does exactly
that joining that I was
diagramming
right here.
So again, it was the discovery
of
these restriction enzymes that
made possible almost all the
stuff that's
happened in biology since 1975.
The development of restriction
enzymes
was essentially,
I was a postdoc at Berkeley at
that point and the labs,
Stan Cohen at Stanford,
Herb Boyer at UCSF,
and a two others around the
country were working on this.
They were almost all labs that
had
worked on bacterial plasmids.
Plasmids are little circles of
DNA,
so the labs that started were
ones who have been busy studying
little
circles of DNA that usually
carry drug-resistance between
cells.
And
so that was happening while I
was a postdoc.
And when I got to MIT in
'76 the technology was just
beginning.
I was one of the first
labs trying to cut pieces of
DNA and join them back together.
So, it's a pretty recent
development.
At that point,
DNA
sequencing hadn't been
invented.
The idea that you could pull
out a
piece of DNA and do something
with it or produce a protein was
just a
thought.
It didn't exist.
So it's hard to overemphasize
how critical
the discovery of these
restriction enzymes were.
Now, I just want to
tell you where they came from,
or how people found them.
And I'll
try and do this quickly because
I know some of you get impatient
with history.
But this is really important
because
it's very easy to make fun of
basic research.
You can ridicule anything
pretty easily,
and you might just ask because
I'm telling you the
story.
Somebody proposed doing this.
I'm going to tell you the
experiment that basically is
the basis of the biotech
industry, and
would you have been smart
enough to recognize that it was
the discovery
of a phenomenon called
restriction, restriction of
bacteriophage
growth on bacteria?
And it was, here are actually a
couple of EM's of these little
plasmids.
This is an electron
micrograph one.
In these little circles it's
been shadowed.
And
this is actually artificially
colored, but that was the kind
of
plasmids that people were
cutting up.
So, as I said,
trying to get
through this DNA,
and the stuff,
what's made possible the
sequencing
at the Whitehead Genome Center
and stuff that I'll tell you
about is going on.
I didn't really set this one
up.
But that's Eric Lander who
teaches 7.012 in the fall.
I told you a
picture from that DNA 50th.
Well, they had a banquet at the
end of it,
and I was there.
This is Svante Paabo from
Europe who is sequencing
the chimp genome.
And that's Francis Collins who
is head of the
entire Human Genome Project.
This is Evelyn Witkin,
who was a big
discoverer of early DNA repair
events.
And I put that one in
because it was sort of
interesting.
There was Eric,
and Savandi,
and
Francis were talking about what
would happen when they knew the
sequence of the chimp genome,
which wasn't done.
And there was an
advertisement,
a poster advertising Jim
Watson's latest book.
And they
ripped that in half,
and were writing notes on the
back all the
way through dinner.
So if you want to see what
scientists on the
cutting edge,
including someone who teaches
701 the fall looks like when
they are not teaching 701,
there is a picture.
So anyway, the discovery
of restriction enzymes was
Salvador Luria,
who I've mentioned.
He was a member of the biology
department, and one of our Nobel
Prize winners.
He started the Cancer Center.
He also trained
Jim Watson, when I showed you
that picture.
This is Salvador standing
over here.
Another thing that Salvador
did, he was a Nobel Prize
winner but he taught
introductory biology.
So I am basically
following in the footsteps of
Salvador.
He wrote a book called,
even though he was a Nobel
Prize winner,
a book called "36 Lectures
in Introductory Biology.
And some universities,
the intro to
biology is taught by whoever is
at the bottom of the food chain.
The
most junior professor gets
stuck with intro to biology.
And here
it's the other way.
I mean you're getting Eric and
Bob, for example,
Weinberg to teach in the fall,
tells you that.
And really where that
comes from is the fact that
Salvador Luria had such an
interest
in replication.
So he trained Jim Watson,
started
the Cancer Center here,
and he also carried out this
phenomenon of
restriction.
And he did this working with
bacteriophage.
And I
know some of you wrote,
you don't like to see old guys
on porches.
So
I got freaked out,
and I took this next picture
out for this morning.
Oh, I've got to show it anyway
for two reasons.
This is Salvador
sitting on a porch at Cold
Spring Harbor with Max Delbruck
who
started, really,
much of the work on
bacteriophage that gave us the
underpinnings of microbiology.
And I put it partly on A)
because
it shows the informality of the
molecular biology culture which
persists to this day,
and B) because Salvador had
such an impish
sense of humor.
You would have really enjoyed
had he been teaching
this course.
Anyway, Salvador was studying
just bacteriophage.
Remember we talked about it?
And they're basically a
syringe, they
injected their DNA into the
cell.
There's an electron micrograph.
The
DNA is up top there.
It goes in, and then the DNA
takes over the
cell, reprograms it,
and makes baby phage.
And I showed you how we make
plaques.
So that was what Salvador
was studying.
And it's a little like what we
are talking about with
Mendel.
He didn't have very many
techniques available to him at
the
time.
He couldn't sequence DNA.
He couldn't do a lot of things.
But he
could plate phage and count,
and things like that.
And what Salvador
was looking at,
he had a bacteriophage,
and he had two
strains of bacteria.
I'll call them A and B.
OK, here
comes the experiment that
founded the biotech industry.
You ready?
You going to fund me?
All right, so what I propose
doing is I'm going to
grow the phage on strain A,
and now I'm going to plate on
strain
A and strain B.
I laid awake all last week
thinking
of this experiment.
So what did I get?
I got a lot of plaques on
strain A, probably something
like 10^9 or 10^10 per ml
because that's
what this phage lysate usually
looks like once you've grown
them up.
And
if I plate them over on strain
B, no phage, maybe an occasional
phage.
So, obvioulsy the bacteriophage
can grow fine on strain A.
It can't
grow on strain B most of the
time, but some variant has
managed to
figure out how to grow on
strain B.
Given our foray into genetics,
I
think many of you would think,
probably as I suspect Salvador
did
at the time,
the thing's mutated.
It's learned.
It's made some change
in its genomes that's allowed
it to grow on strain B.
So, I wonder if
it learned to grow on strain B,
could it grow on strain A?
So, basically what he took was
the phage from that experiment,
and then
he plated them on strain A and
strain B.
And, well, as you might guess,
since it was growing on strain
B, lots of
plaques, and there were lots of
plaques over here.
OK, so it didn't
forget how to grow on strain A.
So, better check over here,
too, need a
control experiment,
so take this guy,
plate it out,
strain A, strain
B, some plaques over here.
That's not a surprise going in
strain A.
We are back to where we started
from.
It doesn't sound like a
mutant, does it?
And if it was a mutant,
everybody should have been
the same.
Instead, when you grew a phage
on strain A, it didn't have
the ability to grow on strain
B.
But if you gave it a chance to
grow
on strain B,
most of them wouldn't make it.
But if it ever did,
it had now acquired the ability
to grow on
strain B.
So it could still grow on both.
But if you take somebody who
had been growing,
something had been growing on
strain A, it lost it.
And so, the idea there was then
that it wasn't a mutation.
Something was
happening in the strain B that
enabled it to grow on strain B.
And if it ever got away from
that environment,
it lost it.
So, the
phenomenon was called
restriction.
It wasn't a mutation.
It was
something else.
And it turned out,
then, that restriction was
due to an enzyme.
An example of this kind of
thing,
then, would be this EcoRI
activity that's able to cut at a
very
specific sequence.
Now, if you are going to have a
set of molecular
scissors inside of you that
could cut at G A T C sequences,
you'd have
a problem unless you did
something else because every one
of your G A T
C sequences would be cut by the
restriction enzymes.
So what the cells that have a
restriction enzyme have,
is a
modification enzyme that
recognizes the same sequence,
and then modifies
it in some way that makes it
resistant to the restriction
enzyme.
And in the case of the EcoRI,
it
puts on a methyl group on this
A.
You might have thought that
that
would interfere with base
pairing, but it doesn't because
adenine looks
like this.
These are the guys that base
pair with thymine,
if you
look back, and you'll see that
you could put a methyl
group in there.
It wouldn't interfere with the
base
pairing, but would allow this
to go.
So, it was the discovery of
this
phenomenon of restriction of
bacteriophage grew on one
strain,
not on another.
It could learn to grow on the
other strain.
It could
lose that acquisition.
It was that phenomenon.
People, didn't have any
other reason other than it was
an interesting problem in
biology
to understand it.
Once they understood the basis
of
it, another whole world opened
up because you could see from
basic
principles, now I could cut any
piece of DNA.
I could generate
these little overhanging sticky
ends.
I could take a plasmid.
People knew about those.
I could find one that only has
one
restriction site.
I could stick things in.
Now I've attached an
origin of replication to each
of those pieces.
And I'm
in business.
I can now, for the first time
ever,
take a particular piece of DNA
and make as many copies as I
want.
And
that was an absolute
transformation to the way people
were able to think
about biology.
So I'm going to just kind of
give you an idea of how
people would start.
So the way people began and
still begin most
things is they'd call it,
the usual term is you call
constructing a
recombinant DNA library.
And there are a variety of
different
ways of doing this.
But this principle is the same.
We'd take
the DNA from whatever organism
you're interested in,
and studying.
And we cut with some
restriction
enzyme.
And this restriction enzyme
will cut wherever there happened
to
be sites.
They might be close together.
They might be far apart.
But whatever,
still generate some
characteristic set of fragments.
And we'll now have,
in this case,
fragment number one,
fragment number
two, fragment number three,
fragment number four,
and so on.
And if it's
my DNA, there's a lot of
fragments.
And of course,
they're all mixed up.
I can't tell where any of them
are.
They're just all mixed together
in
the test tube.
Then we'll take that vector
that we've opened.
And now, we'll mix all of these
fragments together with this
vector.
And then we join it just the
way we discussed.
And now what
we'll get, it's a collection of
plasmids that have different
inserts.
So, one of the plasmids will
have that fragment number one.
Another one of them will have
fragment number two,
number
three, and so on.
Then this whole thing is what's
known as a library.
You can see if it's DNA from
me, there were 3
billion base pairs to start.
Given the human DNA,
G A T C sequences are
pretty common.
You can calculate the frequency
yourself for how many
sites on average there would be
for a restriction enzyme within
a piece
of DNA and figure out roughly
how the fragments there would be
in the
library of human DNA.
So, we are partway there.
We can
now make a library.
We can make it from bacterial
DNA.
We can make it
from human DNA.
But the next thing that people
had to learn how to do
was to figure out how to find a
particular fragment that had the
gene that you are interested
in.
And there's a whole variety of
things.
I mean, ultimately today since
the human genome is sequenced,
you go on a computer and type
and you find it because the
sequence is
all known.
But the only reason we can do
that is because of all the
work that was done in between.
So, I'll give you several ways
of doing
this.
But one of the ways I think you
can see very easily,
and it's
actually going back to the term
complementation.
Remember
complementation?
We had something that was
mutant, and then we'd put
in a wild type gene,
and fixed it up again.
So, for example,
suppose I was studying
histidine biosynthesis in
E.
coli, and I wanted to find the
gene that encoded the enzyme
that I
had just disabled in my
histidine minus mutant.
So, if I have a
his auxotroph,
I'll call it a hisG gene,
for example,
that's one of
the genes involved in making
histidine.
So, since it's a
histidine auxotroph,
if I have it on just minimal
glucose plates,
and I
streak it out,
it's not going to grow.
But if I grow it on minimal
glucose plus histidine,
then it will be able
to grow, right?
So, I've got a variant of this
organism.
It's got
a single mutation in it that's
affecting one gene.
And because I
don't have that gene,
I can't grow on minimal.
If I made a library of E.
coli DNA, which is going to
have a lot of
fragments as well,
and I took that library and I
put it into this
mutant, I'm going to get a big
mess of things,
all the different
plasmids with all the different
fragments that go into that
mutant.
How am I going to find the one
that I want?
Anybody see that?
It's not
that hard.
I'm the mutant.
I can't grow on minimal because
I can't make
this enzyme.
Therefore, I can't make
histidine.
What do I need?
How could you fix me up if you
were a doctor?
What's
the gene we want out of here?
The one that makes that
particular
enzyme that makes histidine.
Yeah, take the whole library,
stick it in
this mutant.
If the gene coming in encodes
DNA polymerase,
I'm not
going to help this guy.
It still won't grow in minimal,
take
a gene involved in making part
of the cell wall won't help.
But if I
put in the, I get a fragment of
DNA that includes the hisG plus
gene,
and I put it in here,
it's going to grow up.
If it has the plasmid that
has, or let's say the vector
that has the hisG plus gene.
So what you've done is a
really, sort of,
you've used that principle
of complementation that some of
you were sort of wondering about
when we
were doing genetics.
So, you'd break a copy of a
gene.
In the
things we talked about,
we bring in a whole chromosome
that included in
it just a wild type copy of the
gene.
With recombinant DNA,
we can
really narrow it down in the
extreme.
We can bring in a piece of
DNA that is only the gene
that's broken.
And we can take the gene back
to the wild type.
One thing, just to
close, you'll see,
if you remember back when I
talked about language
that are not universal,
although the genetic code is
universal, promoters
and things are not.
So I couldn't ever do this with
a human DNA, could
I, because it wouldn't get
expressed.
So, we need some other
ways of finding those.
We'll talk about those on the
next lecture, OK?